Yoga is new for me.
I have actually been told by a doctor never to do yoga,...
...but I made an excuse for the goats.
Coming back to center, we'll switch sides.
Beautiful, the goats are ready to come out.
The excitement I felt throughout my body when I saw the goats walk in...
...was just complete and pure ecstasy.
Hi!
Oh, the babies!
I've never felt that excited about anything in my life, ever,...
...and I've been proposed to and that wasn't even the best day of my life; this was.
A goat, a heavy goat, a big mama goat, began to walk on my back.
Nice deep tissue massage.
Oh, wow!
It was pretty painful.
It was like a sports massage.
Whoa, that was rough.
Yeah, I didn't really do any yoga.
I definitely felt myself distracted; I did nothing but pet goats.
That's how I look when I run as well.
And then exhale, slowly come down.
This is the embarrassing part.